you're watching when keeping it real
goes wrong Vernon Franklin was an
exceptional young man he was the
valedictorian of his high school class
won several scholarships and became the
first person in his family to attend
college he got a good job and worked
14-hour days six days a week
quickly becoming the youngest vice
president in the history of the via Corp
corporation ending the cycle of violence
and drug addiction that had plagued his
family for generations the officers of
his company were wrapping up the usual
Thursday meeting in the South conference
room when Frank Murphy the man who had
mentored Verdun made an awkward comment
burnin great job buddy you the man doing
some skin huh Vernon got along with all
of the people he worked with which in
his heart of hearts made him feel like
an Uncle Tom though he could have
ignored the simple comment his mentor
made Vernon decided to keep it real get
your mother-fucking hand out of my hand
like a man on the back hand side with
oldest crazy job that's
shoot
[Applause]
laverne and I know allow me to
reintroduce myself my name is Paul ain't
beat no up just like you just
been walking around my weight you
weren't funny today
Vernon works at Sonny's filler up on
route 80
he makes 6:45 an hour and stinks of
gasoline even what he's not at the
station it's as real as it can be dollar
I'm gonna get with it down they got kids
and that's real Vernon Franklin once a
heartwarming story of perseverance full
time today
a sparkling example of when keeping it
real goes wrong
[Applause]
you